the king and queen consort depart
Buckingham Palace at 10 20 in The
Diamond Jubilee State coach drawn by six
Windsor Grays and process up the mouth
escorted by four divisions of the
household cavalry
at walking pace the king's procession
passes under admiralty Arch and south of
Trafalgar Square into Whitehall
it passes several government departments
stoning streets and the cenotaph before
entering Parliament Square
the king and queen consort passed by the
Palace of Westminster framed by the
flags of the commonwealth countries of
which he is now ahead
at the end of the 1.3 mile route the
Diamond Jubilee State coach pulls onto
broad Sanctuary outside the West
entrance of Westminster Abbey
ready for the coronation service to
begin at 11AM
the king and queen consort will enter
through the Great West door at the rear
of the procession
up the Nave of the Abbey to what's known
as the coronation theater
with the king and queen consort's
Thrones in the center
between those and the high altar sits
the coronation chair
to the side are the chairs of a state
where they take their seats
these are the different stages of the
coronation the first is what's known as
the recognition
the Archbishop of Canterbury presents
the king to the congregation at the Four
Points of the compass who respond by
acclaiming God Save the King
second comes the oath returning to his
chair of estate the king promises to
uphold Law And Justice the Church of
England and to look after his people he
then signs a document confirming this
commitment the third stage is the
anointing the king's robes are removed
and he sits in the coronation chair
where he's Anointed with holy oil by the
Archbishop of Canterbury this will
happen behind a specially created
anointing screen next the investiture
remaining in the coronation chair the
Archbishop of Canterbury crowns the king
with Saint Edward's crown
next is the enthronement
the king is escorted to his throne which
symbolizes him taking possession of the
Kingdom
finally comes the homage
several representatives of the country
kneel before the new king to do homage
including the Archbishop of Canterbury
and the prince of Wales
the queen consort is then anointed at
her chair of estate and is then crowned
before being escorted to the throne by
the king's side they then both moved to
the altar to receive Holy Communion
the king and then Queen then pass
through the screen to the shrine of
Saint Edward the Confessor where the
king is divested of his cloth of gold
vestments and sent Edward's Crown before
putting on the Imperial purple robe of a
state and the Imperial State Crown
Ed and Anointed The King leaves the
Abbey down the Nave to the Great West
door
the return journey to Buckingham Palace
takes the same route in Reverse but this
time with the king and queen traveling
in the gold State coach
the coronation procession will be much
larger comprising the king's procession
other members of the royal family and a
much larger Armed Forces contingent
after their arrival at the palace the
public will be allowed onto the mall for
a balcony appearance by the royal family
later that afternoon